ok today we're going to learn about
nuclear fission so first of all the word
fission means splitting and we have the
word nuclear here because it's to do
with the nucleus of a radioactive
material so in nuclear power stations we
usually use uranium now uranium has a
large unstable nucleus and we could
utilize this in order to release lots of
energy so what happens in a nuclear
power station is a slow-moving neutron
is fired at a uranium nucleus the
uranium nucleus actually absorbs the
neutron which causes it to come even
more unstable and split so it splits
into two smaller what are called
daughter nuclei as this splitting
happens remember splitting the term for
the splitting a nucleus is nuclear
fission as this nuclear fission reaction
happens lots and lots of energy is
released now this can this energy can be
harnessed in the nuclear power station
and eventually we can generate
electricity from that but we'll get
there in a minute
now apart from these two smaller nuclei
being released we also have more
neutrons being released as well so these
neutrons are also fired out in different
directions each of these new neutrons
that have just been released from this
uranium nuclear nucleus can in turn hit
other uranium nuclei also causing these
to split into smaller daughter nuclei as
well so we can see from what started our
just splitting one nucleus we've ended
up splitting several and again when they
split even more neutrons I
going to be given out as well this type
of reaction is called a chain reaction
it just means that one of these
reactions has caused several other
reactions to occur please also remember
that every single time we have one of
these uranium nuclei splitting lots and
lots of energy is being released so we
have loads and loads of energy being
released so how can this energy actually
lead to what's being able to generate
electricity so in a nuclear power
station we have several different
features first of all we have a reactor
now the reactor is where we have these
uranium fuel rods that we were just
looking at a second ago so this is where
all of our fishing sorry this is where
all of our fishing reactions are
happening so lots and lots of energy is
being released
we also however have these things called
called
control rods now what a control rod is
is these are made out of boron and what
they're for is they absorb some of the
some neutrons so what we can do is if we
can help to control the rate that this
reaction these fission reactions are
happening by putting the control rods in
further or removing them because what
happens is as we've put a control rod in
they absorb some of these neutrons which
are being given off by these fission
reactions in order to slow the reaction
down so that is the purpose of the
control rods so we also have next to our
reactor we have
a boiler okay
now the whole purpose of the boiler is
to take all of this heat energy from the
reactor in order to to evaporate water
so we're turning water into steam so um
remember because during these fission
reactions we releasing loads and loads
of energy that energy can be used to
heat up water to turn it to steam this
theme can then go and turn a turbine
which can power a generator and in turn
generate electricity so we start off the
energy changes that are happening we
start off with nuclear energy lots as
these fission reactions occur we're
releasing lots of thermal energy which
in turns quick evaporates the water into
steam which then converts it into
kinetic energy in order to move the
turbine the turbine spins around and
then within a generator we have that
kinetic energy being converted into
electrical energy that is how nuclear
fishing works